il faudra en réalité attendre quelques
semaines avant que tous les services de
l'hôpital soit en activité
mais quelques semaines après tout ce
n'est pas grand chose alors que les
privadois parle depuis 1903 de leur
nouvel hôpital
celui ci représente le huitième projet
il a été pensé par un architecte
d'aubenas et les travaux ont commencé il
y a trois ans et demi entre le premier
coup de pioche et l'inauguration
les autorités locales ont arraché de
haute lutte un étage soit 46
supplémentaire cet hôpital représente un
ensemble pour ces deux unités de
maternité de 20 lits avec des services
de consultation qui constitue le niveau
du rez-de-chaussée supérieur au premier
étage d'un bloc opératoire et le service
de chirurgie avec deux unités de 30 lits
chacune ensuite au deuxième étage de
service médecine générale avec également
deux unités de 30 lits chacune dans
l'une d'elles une section de pédiatrie
et au troisième étage nous avons réussi
la performance en effet d'obtenir ce
troisième étage alors qu'il n'était pas
prévu au plan initial
on est heureux de voir le mr été
compréhensifs et finalement
ajoutez cette étable en cours de
construction et dans celui ci nous ont
donc intégré deux unités de soins de 16
10 du projet licence avec dans le centre
des salles pour la rééducation
fonctionnelle pour permettre aux blessés
de récupérer plus rapidement au parc
cela représente combien de lits
or il nous fait un ensemble de 172 dit
pour ce nouvel hôpital et je dois
préciser que nous allons conserver
l'ancien dans lequel sont en outre
installé les services d'hospice pour les
personnes âgées avec section de
fonctionnaires valides et invalides et
ensuite dans le pavillon de la maternité
actuel qui se trouve à proximité du lieu
hôpital
nous établirons foyer de l'enfance pour
les pupilles du département que nous
sommes chargés de recueillir entre 0 et
21 langues que l'on majorité voilà donc
pour la fiche technique de cet hôpital
qui soulagera bien des souffrances dans
les cantons qui entourent privat une
aire d'atterrissage pour hélicoptère
s'est même partie des installations et
permettra les évacuations sur lyon quand
elles seront nécessaires l'intérêt aux
siècles dans un petit hôpital le
personnel 10 ans les médecins les
infirmières l'ensemble du personnel
appelé à donner les soins aux malades
n'est pas dépassée par une organisation
aux grandes
c'est à une échelle à fait humaine les
malades ici sont soignés par du
personnel qui souvent ont reconnu qu' de
martissant du pays sa présence d'un mode
est un avantage parce que les malades ne
sont pas des nues
ils sont connus par leurs dents en
voir et on s'occupe d'eux on a un souci
constant et permanent et le personnel
travaille dans un petit hôpital beaucoup
avec son coeur ce qui compte pour
soigner un malade et vous quand on est
malade et qu'on est de l'autre côté de
la barrière
on apprécie en ce sens un peu isolé on
se pose beaucoup de questions et on a
beaucoup plus confiance comme tong sang
auprès de soi des gens qui vous
entourent et qui font très attention à
tout ce dont pourraient avoir besoin